OSEI AUTO
HE'S 100% COMMITTED WHEN HE
TAKES SHSH PENALTIES IN THE
DUMOULIN IS DOWN THE MIDDLE.
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MAKE IT ON .
WE THOUGHT HE WOULD FINISH HIS !
THREE SHOTS ON GOAL.
CERTAIN N  SHOT BY KOPITAR IS
DEFLECTED BEFORE IT GOES UP THE.
TURNS UP THE WIDTH.
CHANGE.
PICK UP FOR PITTSBURGH.
THE  O'CONNOR.
FORCE THE OUT OF THE ZONE BY TH.
DUMOULIN ACROSS, CROSBY,
RICOCHETS TO THE NEARST EVAN
RODRIGUEZ AT THE NET FRONT!
UP.
DENAULT TO DURZI.
PASS IT ACROSS, WATCH THIS.
PENGUINS PLAYOFF SPOT FOURTH AWY
WIDE IAFALLO.
SPINS IS DEEP TO THE IRATE.
HE'S IN FRONTS OF THE PENGUINS .
>> Alex: TREVOR MOORE UP A ABOUG
HIS FEETKEMPE WITH STEAL AGAINS.
THEN CONSTANT M IN.
CARTER.
KEMPE GOT IT.
LOST BIT OF
SEPARATION AGAINST SAN JOSE IN N